[Musique]
aujourd'hui on peut entendre le chant
des oiseaux il ya tout juste cent ans
le bruit de la canonnade vous aurez
rendu fou nous sommes sur le vieil
armand et de nombreux vestiges
témoignent encore de la dureté des
combats de la première guerre mondiale
surnommée la mangeuse d'hommes par les
soldats la colline domine la plaine
d'alsace et les lignes
d'approvisionnement du front allemand
autour de mulhouse un objectif
stratégique pour les deux camps ainsi
son sommet changea de camp huit fois au
cours de meurtrière offensive où chaque
mètre gagné l'était au prix du sang
aujourd'hui le champ de bataille est un
musée à ciel ouvert autant qu un
important lieu de mémoire
nous avons eu des combats très très
douloureux donc il ya beaucoup il ya eu
beaucoup de victimes trente mille
victimes sur le site et donc nous
surplombe on la plaine d'alsace donc
avec donc le cimetière la nécropole
française que vous avez ici avec la
croix du sommet le drapeau français
puisque c'est une et cros paul française
le monument national qui se trouve
dernière nous donc c'est un triptyque en
fait champ de bataille monument national
et tout récemment comme beaucoup l'ont
vue d'entre vous ont suivi
l'inauguration de l'historial franco
allemands de la grande guerre qui est
une pièce maîtresse ici mais sans
prendre le dessus tout de même de ce
monument national qui est l'un des
quatre monuments nationaux de la grande
guerre dès l'après guerre le site est
consacrée à la mémoire des soldats
tombés pour la france
les croix de bois deviennent des croix
de pierre une crypte et un ossuaire sont
construit en 1932 le monument national
est inaugurée dans ce secteur agitée du
front des vosges
on conserve encore une mémoire aiguë des
tragédies qui ont déchiré notre région
nous avons un territoire qui a beaucoup
souffert de ses allers retours entre
l'allemagne et la france que ce soit
donc en 1870 l'heure la grande guerre
vient bien après en 39-45 et nous avons
toujours autour de nous des personnes
qui sont très très impliqué dans la
défense de cette mémoire est dans la
nécessité de la faire perdurer c'est
important
ce travail de mémoire puisse se
pérenniser avec nos enfants parce qu'on
dit toujours que c'est finalement dans
la mémoire qu'on puise la force de vivre
le futur et je crois que c'est important
que nos enfants aient conscience
également de ce qui s'est passé pour
comprendre le présent et préparer
l'avenir en 2008 en prévision des
cérémonies du centenaire le site et
restaurer un parcours pédagogique est
créé sur le champ de bataille le sentier
et sécuriser le monument national et la
crypte sont rénovés et surtout un
historial et construit 7,8 millions
d'euros investis par l'union européenne
la région les états français et
allemands et enfin le conseil
départemental alors l'idée c'était un
travail civique mais aussi historiques
et culturels également parce que ce site
existe on à ce devoir me de mémoire
envers ns envers nos anciens mais aussi
de transmission pour nous pour nos
générations nos jeunes générations le
département du haut rhin a contribué à
sa rénovation depuis 2009 sous le sous
l'égide du comité du monument national
et a participé à hauteur de 1 million de
à sa rénovation
c'est très important pour le conseil
départemental de participer à ces
opérations ces grandes opérations qui
sont dédiées à la mémoire d'une région
sur le plan pédagogique d'abord pour les
enfants parce qu'il ya des grands
programmes qui initie les jeunes au
parcours de la région et aussi pour
l'ensemble des citoyens et des touristes
qui pourrait arriver sur ce site en
prenant bien content de tout ce qui
s'est passé ici pendant les moments
tragiques ont connu une autre région
derrière les enjeux de mémoire celui
plus terre à terre du tourisme
si jusqu'à ces dernières années le
tourisme de mémoire concerné surtout les
passionnés aujourd'hui les sites comme
celui du hartmannswillerkopf attire un
public large et divers un atout pour
l'économie du territoire
c'est vraiment un site stratégique et
emblématique pour notre tourisme au
niveau du canton de cerner mais nous
sommes un petit peu à mi chemin avec
notre canton voisin mais je crois que
c'est vraiment un site phare dans
l'organisation touristique du secteur
autant pour la clientèle
haut-rhinoise alsacienne nationale mais
également internationale et la
fréquentation actuelle le prouve
il y à un passage très important de
visiteurs qui explore le site dans sa
globalité qui fréquentent également le
nouvelliste auriel c'est là qu'ils
découvrent effectivement là l'histoire
de notre de notre canton
ouvert depuis le 3 août 2017 l'historial
offre une vision élargie sur la première
guerre mondiale tout en expliquant les
événements propres au vieil armand un
beau succès public avec près de 60000
visiteurs sur la dernière saison
inauguré par les présidents français et
allemand le musée offre une approche
franco allemande des événements ça a été
un travail important donc deux courses
de conception de réflexion de travail et
de penser aussi par exemple et est ce
que vous avez les présentations qui vous
ont fait ne sont pas simplement
françaises ou allemandes mais c'est
vraiment un travail un travail qui a été
fait un comité scientifique co présidée
par des universitaires et des chercheurs
français et allemand pour arriver à
faire passer un message compréhensible
et respectueux de ce qui s'est passé sur
le site genre de bataille terrible de la
première guerre mondiale
témoin d'une époque où français et
allemands régler leurs différends dans
le centre le vieil armand est
aujourd'hui un important symbole de
réconciliation entre nos deux pays
pas moins de trois présidents de
français un allemand s'y sont retrouvés
pour sceller leur amitié
au-delà de l'impact local ou régional de
ce haut lieu de mémoire il y a un enjeu
qui est très important c'est celui le
locle de la collaboration entre la
france et l'allemagne
en fait ces deux pays qui ont qui se
sont redonné la main pour construire ce
lieu de mémoire se rencontrent souvent
ici et c'est un pour moi c'est un
marqueur très très fort que ces deux
nations se rencontrent sur ici par
exemple au hartmannswillerkopf mais
aussi sur d'autres lieux en alsace pour
le département du hourra qui oeuvre
aujourd'hui justement à la proximité de
ces deux pays ce très très important
d'avoir un élément commun neutre sur la
mémoire du passé des deux pays
un rapprochement indispensable pour
construire un monde où l'on ne verra
plus fleurir les croix de bois dans nos
campagnes